arleux les rencontres de la photographie
avec des stages organisés où l'on peut
suivre les conseils et le travail des
plus grands un seul exemple le stage de
fernando siam transporté à d'actualité
passé depuis à la photo de mode
reportage de jean jacques dufour et dj
dance ouverture en fanfare du stage de
fernando chalana intitulé les jeunes et
la mode china un photographe sur le
manque ni de talent ni d'humour donne le
ton immédiatement je déteste les jeunes
la nouvelle main d'oeuvre et la mauve
aussi qu'on puisse ce sicilien de 46 ans
m l'ironie grand reporter à l'agencé
magnum
il a sillonné le monde et ses tragédies
avant de braquer son objectif du côté
des dentelles pour la première séance de
travail il emmène ses stagiaires en
camargue
une quinzaine de personnes tous des
aficionados du maître aux siciliens ce
comme cartier bresson c'est vachement
shdm en noir blanc vachement monture les
gens ce stage dure six jours prenez cinq
ou six chars ce genre prendre une balle
était sponsorisé par nos parents les
rencontres photographiques d'arles
organise ainsi 30 stage entre le 2 et le
21 juillet on vient ici comme un
pèlerinage c'est un peu la mecque du
photographe
ah bon ouais c'est un peu tous et la
photographie vont beaucoup trop quand
même
warsh a c'est vrai mais china ne fait
pas partie du plan des primeurs
d'ailleurs s'il a accepté de diriger des
stages si presque pour apprendre j'ai
fait surtout des stages pour communiquer
mon expérience est pour recevoir leurs
expériences et peut-être dans le fait
même de communiquer mon expérience en
passe d'autres régions j'ai fait le
point bougeant suis à ce moment
china qui grâce à son expérience du
reportage enrichit la photo de mode
devrait bien réussir à apporter quelques
déclic à ses stagiaires